hey guys it's justine and this is ro
i am so excited because obviously you
guys here on my channel know that i do a
lot of tech stuff
and ro does a lot of food stuff on her
channel yeah and when we combine
our knowledges you get a lot so today i
brought some really fun tech
and it's no surprise that you know like
ro
you are a little uh more petite than i
and most people so for you like finding
like smaller gadgets and things like
that
to work for you is it's difficult
sometimes and you can't tell how short i
am
right now because i'm sitting down and i
have a big butt
and what what does that do so like we
look more even in height but if we stand
up
let's show everybody how short i am i'm
off the camera
i mean they're so cute and just so
little like i just can just like pick
you up and put you in my box i'm a polly
pocket
you are obviously i love tech so today i
brought over three
pieces of tech and i'm gonna call this a
tiny tech series
so we have three things you probably
didn't even notice that they were
sitting right in front of me
oh my gosh you're so small this is like
the macbook air air
air air because it's so freaking small
and this is the ipad air air and this is
the
iphone mini mini mini mini mini
that's five minutes dude five errors i
freaking know
so first i guess we'll maybe check out
the macbook air everywhere
okay and as you can tell this is a
genuine apple product
this is made by apple there's the logo
and i was really hoping that it would
light up
like some of the previous gen um
macbooks because it used to be a thing
it was cool you would open it up
it would light up but this one doesn't
um i hopefully i hope it's charged i'm
not sure
i did charge it before whoa that's a
cool screen
look at the screen and it does this
really cool feature where it'll like
bend
all the way back this is kind of a new
thing that a lot of
like two-in-one tablets are doing where
you know normally your laptop will just
stop right here right now right freaking
goes all the way yeah it's great
oh my gosh uh the specs range i mean oh
gosh there's so many various
configurations which you can get this
laptop in but this one i think we have
maybe the 16 gigs of ram can't actually
quite
i can't read the bottom bar is that that
is that called a
bar that's the dock i can't even see it
to be honest with you okay i don't know
much about tech stuff so i can't see the
dock
very well yeah i'm gonna just put in my
password is there a setting to make it a
little bigger
um yeah let me go into the screen size
here let me use the trackpad so the
trackpad
the one thing that kind of upsets me
about this is it's not centered like
look how the trackpad is not centered
it's off centered the systemic is all
off no
no no no see if i can make the screen
size bigger i do like the keyboard
i just don't like that the dock is so
small i'm having a hard time reading the
icons i wish it was a little bit bigger
but i do like small screens yeah
i have small hands so usually i like
little stuff this is just like really
little
yeah it's very small do you want to give
it a type see how you feel okay
see if you can maybe make the screen a
little bigger see the problem is
the aspect ratio on this screen size
like this is it like the reason that you
would be getting this is because it is
pocket size it's something that you
could take with you anywhere
i mean it's so sweet anywhere so like
you could fit it in a really small
pocket
yeah i feel like you could make
something a little bigger and still fit
in a pocket because this is very teeny i
mean
i'm small and this is like when i
learned how to type in elementary school
a little typing
like class they told us not to use just
her
index fingers but with this situation
i feel like you have to because
otherwise i can't and actually having my
nails done a little pointy
helps really pinpoint the buttons
yeah i don't have any nails so it's been
kind of a struggle for me but it is also
a touch screen
which is nice so you can also click you
know the icons down below to be able to
access
what are these three buttons here what
do they do
here is this for like a quick thing for
volume
or something so a lot of times you know
laptops will kind of have like the touch
bar so apple for a while did have that
digital touch bar but they did get rid
of that so they actually did add
in these physical buttons so you'll be
able to access things
okay like your email very important
and these are the speakers right there
the speakers on this thing
are amazing they're so little yeah so
let's but you're gonna be surprised how
loud this is though so
let me let me pull up a song here okay
pull up a song
okay i mean they're so teeny i know i
hope i can teeny and powerful i guess
okay let me find a song oh
can you i don't even know can you hear
me
this is so loud oh my gosh
i haven't been to the club in like seven
years i feel like i'm ready to go and
party
i feel like i'm there right now yeah we
gotta turn this down
i feel like i haven't get i'm getting a
migraine from that that's that was
intense
they really the technology these days is
getting so good
it's really kind of fascinating because
that is i mean it was such a crystal
clear sound
like even the bass but there was no
distortion it's also getting so much
bigger bigger bigger but now they're
kind of moving more smaller again
yeah so that's the macbook air air to go
with this like
okay okay we also have like i said we've
got our ipad air
and
and what's great about both of these is
i love like the color scheme so they
have them the nice
uh i think they're calling it the
glacier white or maybe an iceberg white
i like that they match yeah me too it's
like this screen is about the same size
as your apple watch
kind of it kind of is giving me those
vibes it's even maybe a little smaller
it's just a hair
smaller do you want an apple watch no
i'm now wearing my ipad
you could just put a nice little you
know thing on that like bracelet on that
and it's super do it from there you're
right and you look at this i could even
wear
the iphone mini mini has a ring like
hello oh my can you imagine you're just
like
hi what's up you could flip it like
around like this
oh that'd be nice that'd be nice oh you
put it in your hair i could
just put it in my ear here look at this
this is
let's see yes
yes oh hold on i need to take a call
hello like
air pods are no more this is the future
you just put your whole phone inside
your hair here
i love it oh my goodness okay like and
then sign me up well they should be out
hopefully very soon and
the one thing that i do like is they
kind of relocated the apple logo up here
okay to the top and that's because that
is now touch id
it's a whole fingerprint id so you'll be
able to unlock your phone just using
your fingerprint on the back
i know right it's great what that's so
cool this is basically the size of your
finger
i mean this is a bit small even for me
but i think if i mess with it long
enough i could get to
to you know get familiar this also
shoots 8k which is
surprising i know but you know i think
the ability to be able to capture this
type of content on something so small is
honestly it's really surprising it's
kind of heavy
for a little thing you know that's how
they're packing all the tech in there i
mean this is heavier than you'd think
you guys this is pretty heavy for a
little thing
the calendar is a huge one i don't even
know if i can see the date on there
um where is that click on it okay
oh shoot that's that's photos that's the
wrong one let me close it out okay there
we go there's there
there so if i actually had to see what i
had to do today
um i can't i can't really see it okay
wait a minute if i got something this
close i can't see it
but it's here i can see it like i've
been re-watching all of the marvel
movies yeah in order from start to
finish like how they were supposed to be
and i feel like they're somewhere in the
marvel timeline
for us in our tiny tech you could glue
it on a nail
if you got a big nail you could
literally glue it on your nail and no
one would know
oh no no oh god is it okay
i don't see a cracked screen it's pretty
durable yeah
um durability test
yeah check let's check out the ipad look
how good that looks
i always love their backgrounds like i
love when they do these like
like i don't know if it's like the
raindrop background or i love these they
just feel so calming
and i love what they did with the mini
mini mini series and the
air they kind of did a nod
to like the original iphone so this is
like the original iphone background and
they kind of went back to the similar
icon design
so you can tell it's very similar to
that i'm feeling like very nostalgic
about this and also the only thing
that's difficult my only criticism
is that these the group you know when
you get your grouped apps
it's so small i don't know what's in
there so you guys might be able to see
what she's talking about like the
grouped apps so when they're in that
folder
i cannot even see what's in there i mean
i'd have to guess
well at this point you're able to use
siri mini mini mini mini and she will
actually answer
so we can have her open stuff for us hey
siri many many many many
uh open up my notepad
so she opens a notepad it's like it's
like
so basically like you can be talking to
it this is great for you
siri doesn't understand me she never has
and i don't know if she ever will
well i'll get you a review unit of this
because honestly it is game changing
let's take one last little picture okay
let's do it
okay okay maybe we should do a quick
little video let's let's okay hold on a
second i can't
well you're gonna have to do you need a
i got a toothpick
is it recording i don't know let's see
hi
hi okay so this is recording on the many
many many many many
many five minutes mini video yay
okay wow this looks actually pretty good
i mean i can't actually see it so i
don't really know what it looks like
i'm looking in this general direction
where i think the camera is
hmm yes i think those were i think those
are right
i think we need vibes i'm so excited
about this um
thank you so much for checking out this
new tech i love checking out you know
new tech and baking with you but man
getting a chance to check out this
revolutionary new stuff that's not even
out yet is like
this is awesome this is blowing my mind
justine i learned so much from you
like sometimes when i get a new phone i
just have to like call you about it
yeah well when next time you call me i'm
gonna be like well
my phone is in my
ear like this is just i just can't even
well guys thank you for watching
i would love to hear from you guys like
what do you think if this tech is to
something that you would use how do you
think this would kind of fit into your
lifestyle i would love to hear it in the
comments below
bro thank you so much for joining and
hanging out make sure you guys go check
out the subscribe to rose channel we
have some more fun videos there
and yeah we will see you guys in the
next one bye
[Music]
you